what up space fam golden here from anime
out pro back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story this chapter definitely
had some big and very hype reveal so
make sure to stay tuned for this one if
you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
videos and want to keep them coming you
know what to do channel the pirate king
within and smash that like button
remember smashing that like button is
pirate king energy and passing is orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one piece videos that's
just the way it works these days and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my big and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the enco warlords admirals
and much more link to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into its spoilers and all so
this chapter is called the tower which
will be so much more significant than i
possibly imagined at first but more on
that in a bit we continue back with the
ultra hype moment of an all-star
actually breaking a sword a freaking
sword off of sanji's face neck we're
again told that something's up with
sanji and i think that's clear to
everyone at this point people are
shocked to see it with good reason this
is such a big flex all the more so
because it involved him doing nothing
while a blade went for his neck it's
made clear that hockey alone wouldn't
explain this and queen recalls judge
talking about making humans more durable
accelerating their healing factor and
enhancing their physical strength so it
all checks out but the last thing he
mentions is what scares sanji the most
he says all these benefits would be
topped off with hearts of ice sanji
fears that and it's understandable
because he wouldn't be him anymore it
really shouldn't be a surprise that he's
freaked out because it would be like the
death of sanji if he lost his emotions
and humanity choppers like we are
initially just excited about the fact
that our boy sanji broke a sword wielded
by aku commander with his neck sanji
though is freaked out because he doesn't
want the heart of ice he doesn't want to
end up like the unfeeling monsters that
are his brothers and rather than just
beating up queen with a hype new
power-up as we may like to see sanji
starts running away wanting to figure
out what caused this transformation and
probably what can stop it before he
ceases to be himself as far as he knows
the more he fights and is pushed the
more he'll cease to be himself so that
could explain why he starts running here
wanting time to think for a bit by the
way i'm a huge fan of stopping and
taking time to just think but it's
definitely hilarious seeing someone do
it in the middle of such an intense high
stake battle but as sanji's thoughts
reveal he's worried if this keeps up
he'll lose his emotions so he's gotta
make sure it doesn't keep up until he
knows more about what's happening as
enemies see him running and mumbling to
himself they understandably decide to
fill him with lead aka shoot him with
several guns and bullets after all who
wouldn't want to be the random dude who
ended up killing black leg sanji in the
pirate world that would lead to some
serious street cred but sanji is like
dragon ball goku now and i mean
specifically dragon ball and not dragon
ball super goku who actually gets gunned
down sanji without his guard up simply
says that hurt after receiving the
bullets but it didn't leave any lasting
damage if swords and bullets can't
actually hurt him he's really become
like the ultimate shield and i like the
view a subscriber mentioned last time
about sanji now really being the pirate
king's shield while zoro is his sword
everyone's obviously shocked to see
sanji being fine after being shot so
many times but you gotta give credit
where credit's due and queen deserves
some because he is not scared or worried
after what he's seen in fact he's
chasing after sanji even wanting him to
put on his raid suit he really wants to
face sanji at his strongest so he can
see what germa science can do and
ultimately so he can defeat germa
science then we jump to another one of
the most hyped up battles kid and law
versus big mom kid is personally one of
my favorites and i really look forward
to seeing him in his evolution because
he's such a cool pirate here it's not
looking good for him though because as
you'll remember hawkins pretty much has
taken his life hostage while fighting
killer via his voodoo powers as a result
kid is on the ground in pain and he's
asked if he's got a migraine or
something which is just hilarious to me
imagine fighting a yonko and just being
like yo i gotta lay down for a bit got a
migraine just wait until this advil
kicks in big mom and law don't know
what's going on and law is
understandably annoyed he's confused and
tells kid to stop being dead weight it's
bad enough to have to fight a yonko but
even worse when someone is actually
slowing you down and you gotta worry
about saving them too as big mom is
about to finish off kid law uses
shambles counter shock hurting big mom
and more importantly distracting her
prometheus is angered that law hurt big
mom and so attacks law of his own free
will and it really looks painful love
the name too stolen fire a play on
german pastry but more importantly a
reference to the fact that the
prometheus from the myth stole fire for
humanity love how oda consistently
manages to incorporate history and myth
while telling his own fascinating story
big mom uses a marmalade slash mama raid
attack on kid and now both kid and law
are down while big mom looks down on
them like a true yonko facing some
annoying brats kid has some good
self-dialogue here as he forces himself
up saying there's no way this is a
headache and even he doesn't know what's
going on but whatever it is he's finally
got an opportunity to take down an
emperor so he's gotta take advantage of
it he doesn't wanna die like this or his
life as a pirate would be a joke law is
conscious but worried and it's pointed
out that kid looks like he'll keel over
by himself at this point even if big mom
doesn't do anything and even though this
may look bad at first glance i think it
looks pretty good in the sense that
they've survived this long while kit has
been more dead weight than help when
killer deals with hawkins they'll be
able to do considerably better and if
luffy can take out kylo by himself
there's little doubt in my mind that
these two together at full power could
potentially take down big mom and i
think that this is where the story is
building to but first let's move on to
another battle that is closely tied to
this one the battle of hawkins vs killer
and man is it easy to hate hawkins not
only is this due to coward he's even
getting in the way of those brave enough
to actually try to take out the yonko
truly irritated by his behavior but i
guess that makes sense when we are
talking about an antagonist we see
hawkins smashing his head on a beam
while he's completely fine afterwards
all the trauma is going to kid after all
which explains his so-called migraine
meanwhile because of the smile killer is
laughing and hawkins even makes fun of
him for it saying he has the worst luck
you really feel for killer who is
begging hawkins to stop he cares deeply
about kid it's definitely one of the
tightest bromances in the series the
crew wants to help kill her but he tells
them not to since he knows what it would
mean he's tried to find a way to win
this because brute force would only kill
his best friend and captain finally he
makes a very commendable and zorro-like
offer he says release kid and hawkins
can have his own life instead hawkins
starts kicking killer around as if we
needed more reasons to hate this guy
he's kicking a man when he's down in the
literal and figurative sense furthermore
he insults kids dreams of beating ayanko
while getting in his way at the same
time killer is annoyed and hawkins
teases him saying he can cut him down
whenever he feels like knowing that it
would result in his captain's death
interestingly enough hawkins still wants
killer to surrender and promises to even
put in a good word with kaido it's
almost like he wants to prove he isn't a
coward compared to killer's bravery he
wants his decision to be validated by
getting someone as respectable and
honorable as killer to make it too he
tries using the reasoning that worked to
convince him he says that their side has
no chance of winning the battle the
reason their dominion over the seas has
lasted for so long is because the yonko
can't be beaten the obvious problem with
this line of reasoning is that nothing
lasts forever even the roman empire fell
and before the yonko there was the
pirate king and before that the rock's
pirates things are in constant flux and
eventually kaido and big mom will fall
it's just a matter of when so assuming
that things will always be like this and
always acting according to that belief
makes no sense it's funny that after all
this talk hiller says that he sees
through his wailing that hawkins regrets
the path he chose and i love this
because it's anti-validation it
completely spits in the face of the
validation that hawkins was seeking for
being a coward it leaves hawkins still
feeling like a coward with no integrity
like a soulless puppet which is pretty
fitting killer goes on saying they
fought through the impossible odds
hawkins foresaw and they're still here
fighting while hawkins soiled his pants
from fear and gave up on his dreams
hawkins says they'll see who made the
right decision when it's over but again
he's just looking at the result arguably
even if they lose or die i'd say killer
and the straw hats made the right
decision not betraying themselves just
to keep their lives which would be
worthless then anyways killer says he
doesn't want to have regrets either so
he'll try again all or nothing a very
hyped statement you know something big
is going to happen either way he asks
what happens if hawkins takes damage
that has nowhere else to go he then cuts
off the arm that kid doesn't have and
hawkins actually gets his arm cut off he
then reveals to hawkins that kid doesn't
have a left arm and removes the final
doll leaving hawkins with just his own
life left to sacrifice this was an
absolutely great fight and such a good
moment for killer he used his knowledge
of his captain and friend along with
hawkins arrogance to find a way to win
in a seemingly impossible situation
because of his powers hawkins dropped
his guard and killer took advantage of
it splendidly hawkins then attacks but
killer cuts the head of his giant straw
man like a yu-gi-oh player hawkins asks
for the heart of the cards to work in
his favor saying that the fate of the
straw man is decided by the cards and it
will be revived but the heart of the
cards betrays him just like he betrayed
his own heart and he draws the tower the
title of the chapter killer finishes the
battle and a defeated hawkins lays on
the ground saying the very hype news
that the tower card signifies great
change an upheaval of the established
order its meaning indicates the opening
of a new path this explanation is also
placed on top of the panels that show
the kit and big mom fight suggesting it
is referring to that fight as well
meaning of course that the old
established yonko order will fall big
mom will be defeated along with kaido
and kid looks ready to go saying he
never felt better killer tells his
captain to go for it and we're told by
the narrator that this man who fights
with blades along with his side is
carving out a new future love all the
puns and absolutely loved this chapter
this was one of my favorite fights in
wano so far even though straw hat or
yonko wasn't in it so props to oda for
handling this so well this prediction is
heavy foreshadowing that the old order
of yonko will never be the same again
after this so it's pretty much
guaranteed at this point and it stands
to reason that the old order big mom
will make new for new and kit and law
may well take her place as the new
emperors leaving shanks blackbeard luffy
kid in law as the emperors of the next
generation shanks would be the only one
from the old generation left so let's
hope really hard that we don't find out
blackbeard took him out after this
battle but that is it for this
absolutely insane chapter had no idea i
would care this much for this fight but
wow did i ever appreciate it as always
let me know your thoughts about this
chapter what you're most looking forward
to seeing next and as always who was
your mvp i feel like you gotta give it
the killer here who absolutely killed it
this may well have been the climax of
his character in the series as far as
screen time and epicness go and it did
not disappoint if you did enjoy this one
piece review and want to keep them
coming you know what to do channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button remember smashing that like
button is pirate king energy and passing
is hawkins energy so choose wisely if
you haven't make this the video you
subscribe this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos that's just the way
youtube works these days and while you
wait for the next chapter to drop feel
free to check out my big and growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all the yonko warlords admirals and much
more linked to that is in the
description and i especially want to
thank the patron squad over on patreon
here on youtube who helped make videos
like this one possible first and
foremost i want to thank the patron of
legend the one acknowledged by lord wigo
himself alpha sigma and other one tier
patrons the ones who stand on top all
clans ingrata al-jatal pate heffa
hirokomi and water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the spike kaido might be a
gyarados dylan isadore spidey life
tennelle tungsten tarkis baked buddhist
cody hebert and jeremy cummings and
their pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh the red-haired raven
steelers angel crews very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy
games and jessica rabbit thank you all
so much if you also enjoy our work you
can support more of it by going over to
patreon.com anime outdoor and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll get access to our private
patron-only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course thank memes so
check out patreon.com anime upload link
in the description if you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed so yeah you
can support more content either way
whichever way you support us you'll get
the same great benefits thanks again and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you